tous les personnages sont attachants et
sont importants il n'y a pas de petits
personnages
salut c'est fred testot bons joueurs
font 30 ans bonjour tout le monde c'est
thomas ngijol
bonjour c'est pascal elbé alias le chef
beaucoup saluent ces isa de mary fifa
lui s'était dit riner salut c'est loubna
gourion ça vous arrive d'aller des mecs
qui veulent pas quitter le plateau
encore j'ai la chance de prêter ma voix
à mme bello wever non monsieur vous avez
une réunion très importante qui commence
tout de suite alors suspendu 30 au
elle est très pepsi elle a beaucoup
beaucoup d'énergie elle est très drôle
moi bah je m'attelais celui que tout le
monde prend pour un flic enrobé qui
adore les beignets je suis en train de
tester l'eau type est bon et généreux et
gentil et jovial enfin exactement comme
moi ont fait le personnage de yack 100
personnages très cool hein
bah oui on est dans un club de
naturistes on n'est pas des pigeons
interprète le personnage de gazelle qui
est une pop star
otto piller est un endroit unique je
prête ma voix un tout petit fennecs avec
une très grosse voix le 17 février le
chef bobo ses limites
secundo nous accueillons parmi vous de
nouvelles recrues que je devrais vous
présenter mais je ne le ferai pas parce
que on sent que une espèce de bourg et
au grand coeur
j'aime bien ça c'est à ces médications
oui mon chéri c'est très bien d'avoir
des rêves alors moi je double boni une
maman lapine une carotte à la fois c'est
une aventure ébouriffante pour les
petits mais aussi pour les grands
alors toi aussi viens voir zutopi prenez
vous le petit frigo a très vite
ciao voilà vous êtes prévenus zutopi
vous n'aurez jamais rien vu d'aussi poil
à